alina you are new to the 90 day fiance
franchise congratulations
thank you
thank you so much oh my god
what made you want to be part of the
show well um
there is like one biggest reason why is
that we don't often see people with
disabilities dating other people
especially like as little people too who
date average height
people
and i just wanna like usually you talk
about people with disabilities something
about concerning their disability but
there is so much more than that to life
so i just
wanted people to see my experience
yeah well i'm so excited for people to
see you and your beautiful face and
personality
one thing that i find is interesting i
think it's great that the show is
offering diversity and casting but i'm
curious to know how that feels to be the
first little person
part of this franchise does it add any
pressure
i don't think it adds any pressure maybe
a little bit in a way that uh i hope i
didn't say anything
degrading to people like me and i was
always correct with my terms
uh that i used to like describe myself
you know um
so but i don't really feel any pressure
i just
think that it's awesome and
i kind of love that i'm the first one
because i'm not really compared to
anyone else
yeah yeah i'm i'm very excited that's a
good point that's a good point well i
admire your confidence and i admire how
even though you have body insecurities
like most of us do you're not afraid to
show up in this world right you're not
afraid to be fierce as your best friend
elijah would say
and i love that about you so can you
talk to us a little bit about
how you got to the point of self-love
that you're at right now and body
acceptance that you're at right now
well you know to be honest it was a
pretty long road and i'm still on it
uh
how you see me in the show it's not how
i always was unfortunately
um
and i wish i i was just you know born
confident and everything else but
it just took a while to realize that
i can be beautiful too if i want to
and everybody can be beautiful and
i don't know it's just kind of
it was a constant work of telling myself
it's okay that somebody doesn't like me
but i still love myself and it's still
okay and also
uh performing helped me a lot too
because
i just you know you just put on makeup
do your hair
uh put some cute outfit and you just
feel so much better
and and then you just see and you're
like okay maybe i don't look like
everybody else but
i still like what i see
and this is i think the most important
thing just to
understand that yes i'm different but
different doesn't mean that uh doesn't
mean worse
that's powerful all right well let's
talk about your love interest caleb
selena and i have a deep connection but
i'm worried what other people would say
is a massive difference between us well
you two met on social media when you
were younger
lost touch got reconnected on the dating
app when he was attempting to come to
russia didn't work out but now you two
are meeting in turkey what is it about
caleb that made you say okay i'm willing
to travel and meet this man and see if
this relationship is going to work
you know uh kind of he seems like a very
interesting person and the first time
we reconnected after a while like after
we lost touch it's just like we clicked
our sense of humor is kind of similar
and for me it's pretty important you
know like to um have fun and everything
so
and he also loves traveling and he's
like outgoing
he has
aspirations in life so
that just really attracted me and he
seemed like
someone
who i want to get to know better and
someone i can confide in because we also
know each other for such a long time you
know
and it's just like
otherwise if i didn't do it otherwise i
would always you know like wonder
right what about caleb you know
somewhere in this airport i'm scared
he's gonna see me in the wheelchair he's
gonna go ew
well there's a moment where in the
trailer where you're in the airport
and you're waiting for him and you admit
that you have a fear when he sees you
that he might stay ill
you know
your honest vulnerable moments what can
you tease about the moment when you two
come face to face
i know you can't well what can you say
i can say that i was just really really
nervous you know to the point where
you just kind of want to throw up a
little bit
because i couldn't believe it's finally
gonna happen after all these years it's
just i never imagined that adding this
random guy on facebook in 13 years i
would meet him
uh
in turkey it's just mind blown really if
somebody told me
uh when i was 15 that well actually you
know what you're gonna meet him what i'd
be just shocked
uh but yeah of course i was really
nervous about
uh
okay so i'll say it that way on social
media
uh and on the pictures that i sent to
calip you can control everything like
you can control all the angles right
yeah
uh but in life you just you are who you
are you know you don't really you know
just only from the best side right
going around so yeah i was just
extremely nervous but at the same time i
was very very excited are you nervous at
all to watch yourself back being that
you are a newbie
i'm a bit nervous of course uh i don't
know if i'm gonna cringe too much
it's like it's an interesting experience
to just see yourself on the screen and i
haven't really had that i mean maybe in
some news reports in my school something
that was filmed i don't even remember
but like that and especially opening up
about your relationships to the whole
wide world
like i'm a pretty low-key person when it
comes to the relationships um but now
it's gonna change are you mentally
prepared for the opinions
90 day fans can be very opinionated so
are you ready for that
um
yeah i'm prepared i
i don't think people are gonna say
something i don't already know about
myself i mean maybe they will come up
with some you know like rumors or
whatever yeah but i was thinking
recently
uh i don't really see you know a lot of
homophobic and racist comments anymore
because people really know that it's not
okay and it is not okay right uh but
for some reason there is not much talk
about ableism
uh
and how people
can say
degrading things about those who have
disabilities and i just want to see how
you know maybe something can change with
the show because more people
would know that it's not okay to i don't
know
shame someone for their height or for
like using a wheelchair or something
um
so yeah i'm kind of
very interested and
see how it unwraps i saw the term
ableism
yeah that's my first time hearing that
yeah see and this is so weird because
there's so much talk about racism and
homophobia especially in russia
homophobia um and
like
but we forgot about ableism you know
and there's so many people with
disabilities um so i think it's not less
important than anything else yeah look
you educating us elena thank you
[Music]